sous le grand chapiteau du cirque dans
les étoiles à aubergenville les trapèzes
et autres monocycle sont orphelins de
leurs artistes
on est les plus touchés du coup
finalement puisque tout s'est arrêté
pendant le confinement est là bas tous
les rassemblements sont interdits les
festivals sont annulés donc nous voilà
toutes nos activités qui sont annulés au
moins jusqu'à la fin de l'été
du point de vue du spectacle alors pour
faire vivre ce spectacle malgré tout
véronique est mis en scène l'un des
personnages sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est que les gens nous répondaient les
gens parlaient aux personnages des
personnes âgées isolées disait qu'elle
était complètement coupé du monde et que
chaque matin elle était contente d'avoir
d'avoir ce petit post avec de l'humour
et du coup ça nous a donné
voilà le la pêche pour essayer d'avancer
[Musique]
monsieur pied a tellement séduit que la
compagnie s'est vu proposé d'en faire un
recueil à l'aide d'une association
locale travaillons avec les personnes en
situation de handicap
petite histoire du confinement peut être
commandé sur internet auprès du cirque
dans les étoiles
de son côté bruno est fait vivre saab
est imaginaire j'ai un petit peu mon
animal à moi c'est un animal imaginaire
et j'ai aimé composer tout voilà toutes
sortes de saynètes toutes sortes de
d'attraction autour de sa grande épopée
pourra être découverte par le public
prochainement en attendant que le
spectacle histoire de cirque puisse
reprendre sa tournée
[Musique]